you are so cool you don't have to hide
that chain it's so cool I do the sound
people told me to make sure because
it'll hit it doesn't bang the microphone
yeah I know oh your accent's coming out
I'll like microphone um so do they do
you're from Australia do they do
Halloween in Australia do you get into
it no we have uh we have no Halloween
yeah B humbug wait what yeah not at all
yeah yeah what why not even a little bit
I'm not sure I think maybe a stranger
danger kind of thing like you're not
really trusting you know it is really
weird cuz I I let my kids go and then
until I became a parent I switch out
their candy at home cuz I'm idea because
I don't trust humans I don't I know that
sounds so sad but why would you yeah
it's you just never know and then like
people scare you on the news whatever um
so you have crazy cool wildlife in
Australia um but you have a lot of
wildlife at your your place in La as
well right yeah because everybody's
always telling me you know like
Australia's Got crazy you know bugs and
spiders and at my house I used to live
right by the Hollywood sign and I had
like a a baby rattlesnake in my backyard
that I had to kind of you know put like
I put on like these micro like oven
gloves yeah and I had like a pole and
there's a this video of me fighting this
rattlesnake like out out of my house and
then also up in the mountains we uh rest
in peace but we had this this mountain
lion who was like 20 something years old
and his name was P22 and he lived P22
shout out yes rest in peace what a
beautiful creature just walking around
in the Hollywood sign I know see I have
a Ranch in Montana we have mountain
lions and I always catch them on my
trail cams they're so beautiful I don't
want to see one hiking no um they tend
to run away from you right but I think
when they get older they get a little
different they get a little well this
one was kind of buff too yeah oh so are
the ones on my land they are
wellfed they Cross by the camera and I'm
like please dear God never see me in
person like yeah but they're beautiful I
love it but there is a lot of wild and
coyotes there's a ton of stuff in La
stuff yeah yeah yeah um okay so I have
to tell everybody this I don't know if
you know this but I found this out about
you you're like quite the photographer I
like to take pictures you you like I
like to take pictures and I'm not good
at it but you're look really good at it
so I want to so you have photos of
traveling I want to show I want to show
everybody this it's so I mean I just
love the shots you do and there's so
many there's so many we're going to show
more so like what what is this there's
obviously a different form of selfie I
love this one yeah this is me and my mom
in uh in London uh four or five years
ago I think and that camera is not brand
new you know no it's it's a it's a uh
it's a rolly Flex I'm not sure when it's
from but it's got this little it's
boring it's like a twin reflex it's not
boring it's so cool it's like something
I would buy and go I'm gonna use this
and then I don't it's weirdly simple
it's not too hard yeah okay yeah well I
heard that I heard that music actually
helped you with your accent like
breaking your accent because I I feel
like that helps me whenever I I grew up
singing classical music and it helped me
take out the twang whenever I sing so I
can put it in and take it out you don't
really have is when I talk I do when I
talk especially if I'm tired or drinking
um
but really hit Tom then um but no but I
heard that music actually helped you
like break your accent right yeah I
think I think it I listen to a lot of
Eminem like a like a a terrible amount
of Eminem So you sound like a tough
American when you talk it was like
Detroit it was you had like a big S of
sort of thing to it and I still love
that man so much and I I have I feel
like more and more I have to thank him
so much you know well he's incredible
yeah I'm a huge fan as well yeah I just
found it interesting to break your
accent you listen to IM
like you're coming into your like
auditions very
aggressive so what other artists do you
like what do you listen to right now I I
mean Bon is my like number one you know
favorite thing to listen to the National
um I listen to a lot of David Boe at the
moment yeah I have this thing with David
Bowie it's like overrated underrated
like he's so rated yeah that then you
kind of go back and you listen to the
music and you're like oh my God this is
it's really good it's so artistic silly
though to say like David Bo is really
good at doing music yes but no but
you're you're kind of right you hit
something there because people know his
name and people like I was introduced to
David Bo from the Labyrinth yeah yeah
yeah I mean it's a CO huge Labyrinth fan
and that's how I got to know but I know
his name more than I knew his music and
then when I got into music I just
started really delving into like his
catalog and he I get what you're saying
he's got an incredible catalog he's like
an ODST just a cross everything you
visual like a yeah it's everything do
you you collect records I vinyl I way
too much right yeah I ha that you like
actually know about it it's stupid I
don't know anything about it yeah a
vinyl no I like I have a lot of them but
I'll like I'll go to like like a
Goodwill and just buy a random ballet
Jazz thing or something and then and
then you listen to it find but it's kind
of an interesting way to like find music
again yeah you find stuff that you would
never you probably can't even find on
Spotify and stuff like that yeah like
that's a way I found um and PE too do
you remember the Miss Elliot song you're
way too young but like there um I can't
stand the rain that song like whatever
but so an peop is the original singer I
didn't even know it was like sampled I
didn't even know and you find you find
all these there's so many Kanye West
ones that you find like so many so many
so many references and then Bon same
thing it's really
incredible as Elvis and the new stopa
directed film Priscilla so tell us
obviously the movie is about Priscilla
that's the title but like what else is
going on in the movie I mean it really
is about Priscilla it's it's uh it's
graceand through her eyes it's it's it's
everything is her experience which is my
sort of favorite part about the film
yeah and it's Elvis through her eyes
which is an Elvis that I think a lot of
people seen before um it's just like a
it's super exciting movie strangely
enough for a movie that's very quiet and
gentle yeah so I heard this about Sophia
did she try and raffle you off to like
get money for the budget like what what
you know I think I think I think there's
laws against that I think sop only had
about that in the press as well okay
they took they took it and ran with it
they never do that no they don't do that
they always tell the truth but but no it
was news to me but I mean I would have
done it in a hobby we did have a pickle
ball sort of tournament running the I've
never played pickle ball oh really I
know and it's a huge thing I that's kind
of why I didn't start yeah it'll creep
up on you I'm a yeah I'm OBS I obsess
over things yeah no it's it's an are you
good at it I'm like
capable you know like I don't are there
Partners in pickle ball I don't want to
be your partner
okay I want someone coming in
strong okay so I heard that you had to
get like an interesting haircut cuz you
wore so many wigs right I did yeah I had
this strange
1950s bowl cut thing that could morph
into his longer hair and it was dyed
pitch black so I kind of I kind of
looked like I was like in Green Day or
oh my God I love it cuz on the weekends
I would have I had eyeliner from from
shooting all week he had the guy liner
and and then it would sort of run and I
I would then you look like Alice Cooper
yes I was I was walking around Toronto
in the snow like with this ball cut like
extremely you know exhausted I had the
bul cut when I was a kid too it was not
attractive yeah interestingly enough it
did you know it carved out a little
personality but anyway um this isn't
your first musical role though right no
did you grow doing music my first role
ever was was a musical and I played The
Cat in the Hat in susal the musical yes
yeah yeah yes
look at how proud you are yeah right now
just so proud I love it I love it I bet
they knew Vin you know from that photo
they're like he's going to make
it yeah they might say that the
confidence I think they I think they
asked me to leave the school after
that no do you do you believe in like
mentorship because I would have loved I
came in like as a teenager and I would
have love to have someone to like bounce
stuff off of do you have any mentors in
the industry I mean nothing nothing so
Direct because I kind of shy away from
advice I'm kind of I don't like being
told sort of what to do but I think just
subconsciously the people that I've
worked with are you a
Scorpio don't know what that means okay
oh it's a I'm a cancer oh you're a
cancer okay okay A little crab I like it
um I'm a little crab yes no I love that
okay I take advice only as advice yeah I
just don't want to get married to any
idea or anything I don't want to get
married
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah there
go but that's great no I I do I do think
that because it's what who makes you you
you your decision making process I get
that um I hear that you're also a jack
caroak fan I am which is I feel like
you're so young for that but that's cool
I feel like that's the only time that
you're supposed to be a jack carck fan
is like when you're young and then maybe
when you're old you can re you can
revisit um but yeah yeah I kind of found
you know on the road at the right time
18 19 uh you know going to America
leaving home you know I've got like fire
in my feet and you know I'm trying to
find the feeling in in things so it was
um it was like a companion you know
novel to my Coming to America and
everything like that yeah that was Jane
air for me that like changed me yeah
that was just that I love that book it
just like I felt it because I moved out
to LA before I or whatever and and I got
very lonely like I can get lonely really
quickly so I it's nice to have things
like that yeah that that was the there
this section in K's book because he's
going and going and traveling across
America searching for his pal and sort
of towards the end he's so sort of tired
and weary and there's this one sentence
and it's highlighted in my copy of it
and he said I wish I could see someone
that had known me for more than five
minutes and that's paraphrasing it or
something like that but that was the
line that like that really kind of
rocked me from that book you know this
idea of having someone that knows your
like soul and movements not just kind of
yeah uh who you are or what you've done
or you know that I had to like train
myself to be good at small talk I was
not that was not my thing I'm amazing at
it now but like I had to like train
myself cuz I'm deeply like I like want
to know everything and I want to get in
a real conversation and know someone and
that's really hard for me to I just sort
of will walk away yeah I'm in that I'm
in the you act strange enough people
want
like he's odd you're like yeah I'll get
away with I'm get away with OD you know
I love that well let's do another break
everybody Priscilla is in theaters
Nationwide starting this
[Music]
[Applause]
Friday thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home